the latest primaries for the November
election are adding to a historically
diverse field of candidates four states
voted yesterday the most notable women
winners included women and first-time
candidates ed O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill
with what these results could mean Edie
good morning good morning John last
night's results set up some potentially
historic elections this November let's
start in Georgia where Democrats voted
overwhelmingly for Stacey Abrams a state
legislator to be their nominee for
governor she's the first black woman in
US history to be a gubernatorial nominee
and if she wins she'd be Georgia's first
black governor ever but she faces long
odds
Georgia hasn't elected a Democrat as
governor since 2019 99 down in Texas
Lupe Valdez the former sheriff of Dallas
County becomes the first openly lesbian
and Latina candidate to win a major
party gubernatorial nomination in Texas
but she faces the popular incumbent
Republican governor Greg Abbott John and
primary fights are often about the shape
of parties rather than the shape of
between the two parties so what did we
learn about Texas is 7th district last
night among the Democrats yeah it's a
significant race and this is a district
that encompasses part of Houston because
we often see outside the state or
national Republican or Democratic
officials try to come in and sway the
results they did that in this race a
woman named Lizzie Pannell Fletcher beat
the activist Laura Moser Fletcher had
been backed by the National Democratic
Congressional Campaign Committee while
Moser was backed by progressive groups
and senator Bernie Sanders but some
national Democrats were worried about
some comments Moser had made about
moving home to run for the seat see that
that just last year they worried that
Republicans would use those
controversial comments against her there
was a slightly different result in a
Kentucky congressional race a former
marine lieutenant colonel Amy McGrath
came from behind and beat the National
Democratic Party's preferred candidate
the former mayor of Lexington to take on
another Republican incumbent who
Democrats believe they can knock off
this November
Thanks